this episode is brought to you by VIN
chair o watches what's up wisecrack
Jared again with the recent release of
jr. R Tolkien's final book and the
upcoming middle-earth Amazon series with
a production budget of half a billion
dollars it's a great time to be a
Tolkien fan but while the growing body
of work set in middle-earth means
everything is always improving for
fantasy fans talking himself was of the
opposite opinion everything is always
getting worse
a self-avowed pessimist toking went so
far as to say that he didn't believe
history would be anything more than one
long defeat this idea of defeat and
decline is the very quality that infuses
his fiction with such a sense of longing
and nostalgia but is progress really a
pernicious myth or was talking hitting
that pipe weed a little too hard
well let's crack open some dusty tomes
and find out in this wisecrack edition
on junior tokens philosophy of history
but before we get there just a quick
shout-out to our sponsor Finch arrow
they've been massively supportive of us
and let us do cool stuff like gets super
nerdy about tolki
right now I'm wearing their chrono s and
it's helped me stop checking my phone
every 10 minutes so I can say on track
making more videos they've got a new
year sale happening right now so if you
want to set yourself apart and step up
your game check out the link below and
watch until the end of the video they've
got great watches for fair prices so
thanks again to Finch arrow and now back
to the show here's a quick breakdown for
the uninitiated you're probably aware of
Tolkien's most famous works the Lord of
the Rings and The Hobbit or at least
Peter Jackson's phenomenal and then just
god-awful adaptations of them
respectively but what you may not know
is that Frodo and Bilbo exist in an
entire token literary universe set in
middle-earth the history of middle-earth
is long and set into distinct ages with
Lord of the Rings occurring at the end
of the Third Age in the beginning of the
fourth but that'll be important in a
little bit these ages are of course
fictional but they also sync up with our
own very real timelines right around the
period between prehistory and history in
other words Lord of the Rings happens on
earth just a really really long time ago
which for reasons I'll get into is quite
important but before we get into why
toking thought everything is always
getting worse we have to understand one
thing
the dude loved history in the lost road
is abandoned book about time travel from
our own era back to the second age of
middle-earth talking through a clearly
autobiographical character writes that
his most permanent mood had been since
childhood the desire to see the lie of
old and Forgotten lands to behold
ancient men walking to hear their
languages as they spoke them in the days
before when tongues of forgot lineage
were heard in the kingdoms long fallen
this deep passion for history shows in
just how much it pervades his writing
there are over 600 references to the
history of middle-earth in the Hobbit
and The Lord of the Rings tokens own
brush with world history had an even
more obvious influence on middle-earth
faithful servant Sam Gamgee was inspired
by the servants who helped officers such
as token in the trenches of World War
one and Sam's journey through the
blasted and barren lands of Mordor is an
unmistakable image of no-man's land
Tolkien's interest extended beyond
events themselves and into the
development of languages literature and
legends husbands citizens and in fact
the exploration of his artificial
languages were Tolkien's main concern
believe it or not the entire history of
middle-earth is really just a history of
the development of tokens constructed
languages talking himself said the
invention of languages is the foundation
the stories were made rather to provide
a world for the languages rather than
the reverse you suppose that it's quite
simple if you want a friend you speak
the password but all's well over talking
was also fascinated by the historical
composition and transmission of the
written word undoubtedly stemming from
his work as a specialist in medieval
culture the conceit for Lord of the
Rings was that it was his own English
translation of a book written by hobbits
the red book of West March incidentally
this fictional book also has a rich
history with no less than five fictional
editions tracing back through writings
made by Sam wise Frodo and Bilbo so Lord
of the Rings isn't meant to be read as a
perfect representation of historical
events but as stories that have been
passed down altered and inevitably
corrupted I wonder if people will ever
say let's hear about Frodo in the ring
yes it's one of my favorite stories so
it's safe to say that Tolkien was
obsessed with history and the process of
writing it but that's what makes it so
strange that his thoughts about history
were so radically different from most
contemporary historians and laymen alike
many philosophers of history especially
those popular in Tolkien's time thought
the move from past to future represented
some kind of progress technologically
we've gotten the wheel the steam engine
and frozen pizza and morally most people
would agree that we became a more just
society after the adoption of the Bill
of Rights and even more so after the end
of slavery and again after the end of
segregation
Martin Luther King's summed up this
thinking when he said talking vehemently
disagreed he thought that our
technological progress wasn't entirely a
good thing and that we weren't
progressing morally whatsoever
proclaiming in on fairy stories the way
men were living in the 20th century was
increasing in barbarity at an alarming
rate while token acknowledged that
technology grew increasingly complex he
mocked the idea that industrialization
represented an advancement for society
he witnessed his beloved boyhood home of
Sir coldest spoiled by the encroachment
of men and machinery
it's a scene which replace itself during
the scouring of the shire in which trees
are needlessly uprooted to make room for
ugly rows of housing and a pleasant
water mill is replaced by one billowing
black smoke all over the countryside in
the lost road he conflates the human
Kingdom of númenor 'he's
industrialization with their cultural
decay our towers grow ever stronger and
climb ever higher but beauty they leave
behind upon the earth men are ceasing to
give love or care for the making of
other things for use or delight in the
Hobbit Tolkien claims that technological
development is a symptom of orcish
thought commenting it's not unlikely
that goblins invented some of the
machines that have since troubled the
world especially the ingenious devices
for killing large numbers of people at
once four wheels and engines and
explosions always delighted them
those wheels and engines were rolled out
for the first time in the form of tanks
upon the Western Front we're talking at
the Battle of the Somme witnessed
firsthand the Goblin work wrought by the
explosive power of modern artillery
despite the horrors of trench and
chemical warfare many of tokine's
contemporaries at the time regarded the
Great War as emblematic not only of
technological progress in the form of
more innovative means of mass killing
but as a necessary step in human history
for social progress - tokine always the
pessimist disagreed
he believed conflict to be inevitable
and recounted years later that this idea
arose as a reaction to the contemporary
discussions about a war to end all wars
he didn't believe such rhetoric during
the war and disliked it even more after
it that conflict must be perpetual is
part of his idea of history as being
cyclical instead of there being a
straight line from a primitive past to a
more civilized future toking envisioned
societies throughout the ages all
dealing with the same perennial set of
circumstances arising from unchanging
human nature will make hopes as of a
soul many of the events in middle-earth
are meant to be reminiscent of the past
so we have Frodo nine-fingered in
possession of Sal Ron's ring during the
Third Age aka Lord of the Rings which
resembles another amputee hero from the
past barren one-handed who recovers a
magic jewel from saurons former master
in the first stage but tokine is no
George Lucas building a second Death
Star or JJ Abrams creating a third and
good god I hope not a fourth the
repetition of this motif is not the
result of a lazy author returning to the
same well for lack of an original idea
rather Frodo bares likeness to Baron
because the world they inhabit though
separated by thousands of years is once
again in similar straits history is
repeating itself because it's cyclical
[Music]
[Applause]
but the history of middle-earth is not
simply cyclical its cyclical but always
getting worse these overarching cycles
in the history of middle-earth were
broken up into four distinct ages that
illustrate history as degradation these
bear conspicuous resemblance to Hesiod
and Ovid's myths of the age of man in
which they established the now-familiar
pattern of gold and silver bronze and
iron ages in mankind's Golden Age
perfect people lived in an eidetic state
of nature not dissimilar to the elves in
Toki's first age coming to live among
the gods in the earthly paradise then
succeeded the silver and bronze ages
each progressively worse for man and
filled with worse men followed by the
current Iron Age the most evil and
unhappy yet likewise across the ages of
middle-earth there's an overriding
entropy each cycle less mythic and more
mundane there is a grandeur in the past
that can be echoed in the later ages but
never fully recaptured son science
consider Rome aka the city on seven
hills which Caesar Augustus bragged he
left as a city of marble yes the real
world remember Tolkien's history happens
before our own real history to drive the
point home we learned that many of the
cities that preceded Rome also are
adorned with marble and have seven of
something but the further back in time
we go the more grander we see in the
Third Age it was the seven leveled city
of Minas Tirith and Gondor in the Second
Age there was the city of Rome enough
from which Tolkien implies that Rome
derives its name in the first stage
there was the original and oldest the
seven gated city of Gondolin but as
grand as we know Rome was in its heyday
toking would say it had nothing on Minas
Tirith during the reign of King Eleazar
and then he would have said yeah but
this ain't nothing compared to Numenor
and its golden age though he'd probably
say it's slightly more regal II and King
elros of númenor would have said too
that y'all should hear my dad talked
about Gondolin when turgon was king
before those dragons burned it all down
to the ground again more regally
point being for tokine older equals
better having the same pattern repeat
time and again throughout the cycles of
history but becoming progressively a
poorer and poorer copy is his way of
illustrating that point the blood of
númenor is all but spent it's pride and
dignity forgotten tokine's portrayal of
history can be partially attributed to
aesthetics toking wished to imbue his
work with a medieval flavor and the
medieval period is primarily viewed as
the ruins of a more glorious antiquity
because in the history of middle-earth
each age is inferior to the one which
preceded it its whole history is imbibed
with the nostalgia for a past that can
never be recovered if I decide to look
upon the King's evolved
I can but it's also as we mentioned a
direct challenge to the myth of progress
instead he favors looking backward and
appreciating past perennial and even
eternal matters it's for this reason
that the noble knights of Gondor always
looked westward before eating each meal
we look toward Numenor that was and
beyond to elven home that is and to that
which is beyond elven home and ever will
be his friend CS Lewis coined the term
chronological snobbery to describe those
who had an irrational preference for
anything new over anything old but
tokine was no mere Debbie Downer he had
an actual philosophy of history that he
espoused one which he and Lewis shared
with the medieval minds they spent their
careers studying middle-earth and the
real world are in a constant decline for
talking because of the way he
understands the fundamental nature of
reality
tokine and lewis believed that evil was
real not some idea or social construct
but a real and powerful force indeed the
most powerful force in the world
sometimes tokine would portray evil as
personalized as with Sauron or with
Sauron x' master from the first age
Morgoth who was himself more powerful
than all the forces of good in the world
combined
but tokine also portrayed evil as an
impersonal force something even the most
pure and innocent hearts were capable of
being bent towards gandalf refuses the
ring for that very reason knowing he
could and would be corrupted it's worth
remembering that when he stood at the
cracks of doom
Frodo failed he abandoned his mission
gave in to temptation and took the ring
for himself
the ring is mine
[Music]
tokine called earth morgoth's rape
justice our on port most of his potency
into the one ring his master Morgoth
poured his spirit throughout the earth
and everything else in existence
so whereas particular lized evils like
sour on could be addressed there is a
primordial evil in existence that will
remain until the earth itself is
destroyed it's because of this belief
that he stated I do not expect history
to be anything but a long defeat this
was what tokine originally envisioned as
the ending for his book of lost tales
and now in the end of fair times comes
very nice and behold all the beauty that
was yet on the earth fragments of
unimaginably Ness
now goeth it all up in smoke the same
despondent pessimism is best surmised by
Frodo as he lay dying on the cliffside
of Mount Doom it's like things are in
the world hope fails and end comes we
have only a little time to wait now we
are lost in ruin and downfall and there
is no escape but of course Frodo lives
and the ring the stand-in for the
inherent evil of the world is destroyed
so what gives was tokine chickening out
from taking his view of history and evil
to their logical conclusion did he feel
compelled by the conventions of the
genre to have a happy ending well that
would certainly make sense after all he
did right I would venture to assert that
all complete fairy tales must have the
consolation of the happy ending the you
catastrophic tale is the true form of
the fairy tale and this highest function
of all the many words in the many
languages that Tolkien invented this
word eucatastrophe is undoubtedly the
most important he defines it in its
fairytale setting a sudden and
miraculous grace never to be counted on
to recur it does not deny the existence
of disk attached Rafi of sorrow and
failure it denies in the face of much
evidence if you will
Universal final defeat giving a fleeting
glimpse of joy joy beyond the walls of
the world
so basically everything will continue to
go too but there will be a sudden change
toward good fortune that works against
this dire conclusion now beyond the
walls of the world here is telling
tokine alludes to another force as
Gandalf hints to Frodo
other forces at work in this world Frodo
besides the moon Aviva Dober was meant
to find the ring in which case you also
were meant to have it and that doesn't
encourage a thought later
agent Smith doing his best Morpheus
impression elaborates you have come and
are met here in the very nick of time by
chance
so it seems yet it is not so believe
rather that it is ordered that we who
sit here and none others must now find
counsel for the perils of the world so
something is driving history toward a
goal this kind of view catastrophe isn't
limited to fictional stories toking
thought that real history contains a
fairy story or a story of a larger kind
which embraces all the essence of fairy
stories as such toking envision the end
of history as being likewise you
catastrophic that though history would
be nothing more than the long defeat it
would ultimately have a happy ending as
unexpected as the Eagles arriving at
Mount Doom ultimately this was grounded
in what tokine called estelle more than
merely being aragorn's elvish name
Estelle was one of the two elvish words
meaning hope which also meant trust all
throughout life toki looked around the
world and between the scouring of his
own boyhood shire his living through a
veritable Mordor in the trenches of the
Western Front and later while writing
Lord of the Rings witnessing the rise of
real Dark Lord's and Hitler and Stalin
tokine had no reason to look up and
reasonably expect good and yet through
it all he never faltered in estelle
entrust just as toki is writing awakened
an appreciation of the past among the
chronological snobs that had been so
enamoured by modernity so to do his
myths stir something in us that
certainly hopes for there to be real
good in the end
when we read The Silmarillion or The
Hobbit or most especially Lord the Rings
we're all like Sam in the black of night
in the enemy's own land struck by the
beauty of a white star twinkling above
him there peeping among the cloud rack
above a dark tor high up in the
mountains Sam saw a white star twinkle
for a while the beauty of it smote his
heart as he looked up out of the
Forsaken land and
Oh return to him for like a shaft clear
and cold
the thought pierced him that in the end
the shadow was only a small and passing
thing that there was light and high
beauty forever beyond its reach thanks
for watching guys and if you haven't
noticed already I'm a recent watch
convert this Ventura watch actually
helps my productivity massively because
every time I check my phone I get sucked
into my 8000 other notifications but
even if you don't have a YouTube channel
to run watches are a low-key way to turn
heads and up your style game they've got
a pretty distinct look and quality feel
more importantly they're having a huge
New Year sale it's on the entire site
and you'll be able to earn up to 25% off
your entire order and hey don't trust me
just some dude on the internet trust
there are over 13,000 five-star reviews
that's more reviews than all of our
podcasts have combined so check out the
link in the description or just go to
Ventura watches comm slash wisecrack
sale to check out their collection and
get up to 25% off when it comes to not
looking like a schmuck I'm gonna take my
chances with the company that's name
literally translates to I will win
so go decide for yourself check out the
link in the description for up to 25
percent off as part of their new year
sale and as always thanks for watching
guys peace